bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission les
petits bricoleurs aujourd'hui je vais
vous montrer comment fabriquer un cadre
de photo
pour fabriquer notre cadre photo nous
avons besoin de trois pièces
d'un carré de 22 sur 22 donc une partie
pleine pour le dos
le devant que j'ai découpé en carrés
pour pouvoir mettre la photo et le
support pour mettre derrière
alors donc pour cela nous avons besoin
de l'alcool
là dessus d'un pinceau
d'une paire de ciseaux d'un crayon
papier d'un stylo brillant
de la peinture de la couleur de votre
choix
et des paquets de journaux et de vieux
magazines
dont vous avez chez vous
alors la première étape on va desserrer
le journal en morceaux
laon wallemme de l'accord
alors donc on va
commencer à coller
alors donc on met la colle sur le carton
nous prend son pied
donc on retourne
il
surtout bien faire tout le tour comme ça
ça va faire plus pour le bo
donc on a mis et le papier journal sur
la première partie sur le dos du cadre
et sur le support
est donc maintenant on va assembler les
trois pièces
voilà donc là on va coller tout le tour
enfin vous faites on va coller trois
côtés on va laisser en haut pour pouvoir
glisser la photo il faudra bien tenir
voilà
donc là on va coller le côté
tous
à
donc là on a bien refermé les trois
côtés donc bien laisser sécher
évidemment
et donc l'étape suivante on va mettre le
son support
bon au milieu évidemment donc je mets la
colle sur le support
alors juste sur environ sur 5 cm on
n'est pas la colle partout
on va mettre au milieu de là
on va le positionner là comme ça
ben voilà on va laisser sécher aussi
alors donc on va passer la décoration
vin va passer on va plaindre maintenant
le cadre de photo donc apprendre la
peinture
pour nos peines autres le vert et un
seul pour le marin
voilà donc étape suivante va vous prenez
de la peinture et vous peignez comme
vous voulez vous
mais moi je mets au bord mais pouvait
voilà un premier temps et ensuite on
peut rajouter du verre
sur l'autre partie par exemple
on peut faire attention pour ne pas
mélanger le moment hello there
vous pouvez passer une deuxième couche
c'est comme vous voulez sauver laisser
comme ça où ça fait un effet craquelé
donc le temps de séchage
le cadre photo étant terminée moi j'ai
choisi la couleur vert et marron et vous
prenez la couleur de votre choix et moi
j'ai rajouté une petite fleur mais vous
pouvez ajouter des pierres des des
strass selon votre goût 1 et moi je vous
dis à la prochaine émission et au revoir
m